terminó la cuarta fecha de fase de
grupos de la Copa Libertadores un torneo
que estaba muy emocionante prácticamente
que no hay ningún favorito Claro en esta
temporada River Plate Así que
complicando su clasificación a octavos
de final prácticamente el conjunto
millonario no tiene margen de error A
falta de dos fechas para el final de
esta instancia empate a una noche en sus
visitas Sporting cristal en Lima en Perú
por el grupo de duelo en el que Miguel
Borja falló un penalti para los de
Martín de michelis Yo soy maryotún fue
quien adelantó a los locales en el
minuto 63 pero Sporting cristal se quedó
con uno menos 10 minutos después de ese
tanto inicial por la expulsión de Rafael
lutigger Rodrigo aliendro fui quien puso
las tablas a seis minutos para cumplirse
el tiempo reglamentario expulsado sobre
el tiempo añadido el venezolano Salomón
rondón por ese mismo grupo de stronges
de Bolivia ganó a fluminense el equipo
de Río de Janeiro lidera el grupo con
nueve puntos seis tiene de stronges en
este momento con 4 puntos está utilizar
los mismos que tiene River Plate que es
colista por diferencia de goles de
stronges que le quitó el invicto en esta
copa fluminense y sueña con los octavos
escuchemos en momentos Nos tocó sufrir y
en momentos Nos tocó jugar y creo que el
equipo se mantuvo firme se mantuvo
contundente siempre con nuestra idea
firme de de de jugar y hacer respetar
nuestra localía nada contento por por
estos tres puntos importantísimos que
nos sigue que nos deja Obviamente con la
clasificación ahí ahí sobre las manos no
en otros resultados para cerrar esta
cuarta fecha metropolitanos cayó ante
internacional de Porto Alegre en el
grupo b y quedó eliminado en el grupo H
Olimpia ganó a patronato y este
resultado convirtió a Atlético Nacional
de Colombia en el primer conjunto
clasificado ya a los octavos de final